what is the standard deviation and what
is the difference to the variance the
standard deviation is a measure that
indicates how much data scatter around
the mean here is a simple example let's
say we measure the height of a small
group of people the standard deviation
tells us how much our data scatter
around the mean so first we need to
calculate the mean we can get the mean
simply by summing the heights of all
individuals and dividing it by the
number of individuals let's say we get a
mean value of
155 centimeters now we want to know how
much each person deviates from the mean
so we look at the first person who
deviates 18 centimeters from the mean
value the second person deviates 8
centimeters from the mean value the
third 15 centimeters the fourth eight
centimeters the fifth nine centimeters
and finally the last person deviates 6
centimeters from the mean value simply
said people that are very tall or very
small deviate more from the mean value
but we are not interested in the
deviation of each individual person from
the mean value value we want to know how
much the person's on average deviate
from the mean value so how much do these
persons on average deviate from the mean
value this is what the standard
deviation tells us in our example the
average deviation from the mean value is
11.5 centimeters to calculate the
standard deviation we can use this
equation Sigma is the standard deviation
n is the number of persons x i is the
size of each person and X bar is the
mean value of all persons so the
standard deviation is the root of the
sum of square deviations divided by the
number of values we calculate the size
of the first person minus the mean and
square that the size of the second
person minus the mean and then square
that and so on until we arrive at the
last person then we divide this number
by the number of people so six the
result is a standard deviation of 11.5
centimeters so each individual person
has some deviation from the mean but on
average the people deviate 11.5
centimeters from the mean which is the
standard deviation now you might notice
one thing I always talk about the
average deviation from the mean but for
the average deviation we would actually
just add up all deviation and divided by
the number of participants just like you
calculate a mean value right you're
absolutely right but there are different
mean values in the case of the standard
deviation it is not the arithmetic mean
which is used but a quadratic mean so
far is the good but now there's one more
thing to consider there are two slightly
different equations for the standard
deviation the difference is that in the
first case we divide by n and in the
second case by n minus 1 but why are
there two different equations usually we
want to know the standard deviation of
the population for example we want to
know the standard deviation of the
height of all Austrian professional
soccer players now if we had the height
of really all Austrian professional
soccer players we would take this
equation in with 1 divided by n however
it is usually not possible to serve the
entire population so we draw a sample
then we use the sample to estimate the
standard deviation of the population in
that case you use this equation with n
minus 1. to keep it simple if our survey
doesn't cover the whole population we
always use this equation
likewise if we have conducted a clinical
study then we also use this equation to
infer the population but what is the
difference between the standard
deviation and the variance as we now
know the standard deviation is the
quadratic mean of the distance from the
mean the variance now is the squared
standard deviation so we have one at the
same equation the only difference is
that in order to calculate the standard
deviation we take the root and in order
to calculate the variance we don't
because the root is taken the standard
deviation is always in the same unit as
the original data in our case
centimeters for this reason it is
advisable to always use the standard
deviation to describe data as this makes
interpretation easier the variance is
more difficult to interpret because the
unit is the square of the original unit
in our case centimeters squared thanks
for watching and I hope you enjoyed the
video